the enduring popularity of the witcher
books and games means that long-time
fans of the franchise have strong
opinions many feel protective over these
characters since they have lived with
them longer than the netflix show has
existed geralt himself is one of the
things that fans are most protective of
for season 2 actor henry cavill
requested one change in regards to how
geralt should be portrayed specifically
that he'd be a bit more vocal and this
is for the best as far as die hard fans
are concerned as it makes him closer to
how he's portrayed in the books season 2
has received a better reception than the
first which was criticized by many over
its confusing use of multiple timelines
so it's clear that the creators of the
show were listening it took me to the
fourth verse to understand their
different timelines
that magic kiss that was a bit cheap
still even though the show is clearly
improving as it goes along it doesn't
mean fans don't have their gripes with
how season 2 adapts the beloved source
material it's based on there is one
season 2 scene in particular that fans
have not exactly appreciated one of the
running threads in the witcher is
geralt's horse roach roach is a constant
companion to geralt but it is not always
the same horse geralt has had many
roaches during his long life but has
loved every one of them that is what
makes it so devastating when the
audience is forced to watch roach be
killed in season 2 episode 6. while on
the road geralt and siri encounter the
deadly monolith beast that was briefly
glimpsed earlier being a witcher geralt
is able to successfully keep the monster
at bay unfortunately roach is just an
elderly horse and gets caught in a
crossfire this doesn't end well for the
poor animal who dies a bloody death in
the aftermath of the battle the scene of
geralt being forced to say goodbye to
his faithful friend caused a bit of an
uproar in reddit one user posted
obviously we all know giving geralt's
age that he's had multiple roaches we
also know he'll have more in the future
knowing that and seeing roach lying on
the ground ripped to shreds two entirely
different things
some fans were just heartbroken with one
user admitting i haven't felt this gut
wrench since hedwig died on twitter one
fan posted they didn't have to show us
roach's entire death scene but i guess
they decided it was worth it
while another shared pride over roach's
death it's true in all fairness the
witcher treats roach's death as a pretty
massive story beat and the horse's
demise receives the same attention as
most human deaths in the show do if not
more however this doesn't remove the
salt from the wound the brutal death of
roach is not something that occurs in
the source material and even worse
geralt ends up being the one who
ultimately has to put roach out of his
misery though such events may well have
occurred during the witcher's long life
before even he's somewhat shaken by the
incident as such it's easy to understand
that this is a moment that many fans
simply could not get behind nevertheless
the people behind the show already knew
that the show's roach was getting older
than a horse can believably be and must
die at some point in any case as such
they were adamant that geralt's poor
steed gets ascending off it receives
showrunner lauren schmidt his rick told
gamesradar in terms of how we killed off
roach i thought if we're going to do
this i want to make it a part of the
story i don't want roach to die off
screen and no one ever mentions it being
the witcher expert that he is henry
cavill personally wrote the little
eulogy geralt gives to say goodbye to
roach
enjoy your close walk across the meadow
and through the mist
historic told gamesradar when we kill
roach on screen henry actually wrote
what he says to the horse it was wildly
emotional it really felt like saying
goodbye to a character we wanted to make
sure that we honored it in the right way
and that we made his death heroic the
witcher season 2 is available for
streaming on netflix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]